[موسيقى]
وادي السيليكون ليس موجودًا هنا في بالو
ألتو فقط على الرغم من أنه بالتأكيد
مسقط رأس العديد من الشركات
التي تأسست في وادي السيليكون ، لكنه
يمتد بقدر ما أود أن أقول كوبرتينو
وشمالًا نحو ريدوود سيتي ، لذا فهو
نوع من التحلي بالمرح  اسمي
نانسي كوبا وأنا مؤسس
ورئيس مقهى Kubik في بالو ألتو
كاليفورنيا هنا في قلب
وادي السليكون المقهى فريد من نوعه
من نواح كثيرة أعتقد أن
الجو المحيط دافئ
للغاية ومرح والآخر  هي مشروباتنا في
طعامنا ونحن نقدم
التخصصات الفنزويلية التي لا يقدمها أي شخص آخر ،
وأعتقد أن الكثير منهم يرغبون في القدوم
لأنهم يريدون مقابلة الأشخاص المناسبين
وهم هنا من أجل اتصالات
العمل والشبكات وهو أمر
مهم للغاية هنا في  وادي السليكون
هو المكان المناسب
للتواجد والتواجد والتسكع والتعرف على أشخاص جدد.
لا توجد عضوية مطلوبة ، يمكنك فقط
الدخول لإجراء حجز عبر الإنترنت ، مرحبًا أنا لارا
ريدمان وأنا أدير التسويق
وتطوير الأعمال هنا في Hana house ،
وهو مقهى ومساحة عمل مشتركة في وسط مدينة
بالو ألتو ، لطالما كانت هذه المساحة
مكانًا للتجمع المجتمعي  لذلك تم بناؤه
كمسرح سينما في عشرينيات القرن الماضي ،
تم تحويله إلى مكتبة لبيع الكتب في
وقت ما وكان فارغًا لسنوات عديدة
قبل أن نعيده إلى الحياة
كمقهى في مساحة عمل مشتركة ، ما
هو مهم حقًا هو ذلك  أنت نوعًا ما
تأخذ فكرة الاجتماع على فنجان من
القهوة إلى المستوى التالي من خلال
توفير بيئة اجتماعات أكثر احترافًا
هنا حتى تتمكن من استخدام
على سبيل المثال بعض السبورات البيضاء التي
لدينا الكثير من المكونات الإضافية ، يمكنك
الجلوس هنا  استخدم بعض
غرف المؤتمرات التي لدينا ، لذلك أعتقد بشكل أساسي
أن ما ينقص
المنطقة هنا
[موسيقى]
NOLA هو مطعم مقره الكاجون ولدينا
قائمة مركزية في نيو أورلينز ولدينا
بعض النكهات المحلية بالإضافة إلى
النكهات اللاتينية والآسيوية لقد طلبت قائمتنا ، لقد
كنا هنا منذ حوالي 22 عامًا ،
اسمي سرب الهرولة ، المدير العام
هنا في Noland Palo Alto ، لدينا
شيء لكل شخص لديك
كل شيء من جامبالايا إلى فرايد
تشيكن ، إنه مكان رائع للقدوم
لساعة سعيدة بالإضافة إلى المواعيد الأولى
للتجمعات العائلية والحفلات الكبيرة ، نقوم
بكل شيء هنا في مبنى تاريخي قديم
يعود إلى
بدايات بالو ألتو ،
تم بناء النصف الأمامي للمبنى في أواخر الثلاثينيات
فقط نصف المبنى المبني  في
أوائل الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ، يعود هذا إلى
عهد بالو ألتو الذي يعود إلى الحرب العالمية الثانية والذي لا
يمكن للجميع القيام به ، ويمكنك الاستمتاع
ببعض النكهات الحديثة التي نقدمها ولكن
أيضًا بعض من وسط مدينة بالو ألتو التاريخي القديم
[الموسيقى].